字幕: Takahiro Shimpo
校正: Hiroko Kawano
皆さんは 子供の頃
どんな夢を持っていましたか？
きっと夢って
色々と変わってきたと思います
でも小さい時は
お菓子屋さんになりたい とか
お医者さんになりたい とか
サッカー選手になりたい とか
ヒーローになりたい とか
それぞれいろんな夢を
持っていたと思います
私も今 ちゃんと夢を持っています
ですが 小さい時に
その夢を持てなかった
そんな時期がありました
そんな私と同じような子供たちが
実は今現在も世界中で
そして この日本にも
いるということを
皆さんには知っていただきたい
と思います
まず始めにちょっと
私のお話をさせてください
実は私は今 お母さんと２人で
日本で生活をしています
私自身はペルシャ絨毯に乗って
イランからやって参りました
（笑）
絨毯は嘘ですけど
でも８歳の時に日本に来て
もう かれこれ
20年が経っているんですけれども
この20年間っていうのが
本当に濃厚で
色んな出来事がありました
これが私の母です
「よく似てるね」って
言われるんですけど
実は私と彼女は
血は繋がっていません
私は３歳から７歳を
施設で過ごしました
彼女が施設に来て
私を引き取ってくれた
セカンドマザー
養母になります
彼女が私を引き取る前までの
私の名前はサヘル・ローズではなく
ナリゲスっていう
名前だったんです
そして 出[生]届もなかったので
私自身正直 いつ生まれたのか
わかりません
彼女が引き取ってくれた後に
私に誕生日とか
今の名前を与えてくれました
きっと彼女と出会えていなければ
今の私はないと思っています
でも 彼女は私を引き取ることで
沢山 苦労したはずです
その苦労があって
正直 自分の国に居場所を
なくしてしまったことがあって
今 こうして日本に来ることになったのも
色んな方の手助けがあり
日本に私たちは20年前に
来ることになりました
でも 言葉が分からなくて
仕事もなかなか見つからなくて
公園で生活する時期も
あったんですね
その時 救ってくれたのが
この方です
彼女は私が通っていた
小学校の給食のおばちゃんです
公園で生活をしていた
私たち 親子を
自分の家にかくまってくれたり
お母さんに仕事を与えてくれたり
言葉を教えてくれたりと
沢山 面倒を見てくれました
ランドセルも自分のお子さんが
使ってたのを
私にくれました
血の繋がりがない私たちを
全く血の繋がりがない
この給食のおばちゃんが
また 助けてくれたわけです
ですから 私もお母さんも
彼女以外にも多くの方々に救われて
今があるので
本当に日本の方に
心から感謝をしています
そして大好きです
だからこそ そんな皆さんに
知ってもらいたいことが沢山あります
今日 伝えたいのは これ
この数字は2013年度に発表された
今現在 児童養護施設で
生活をしている子供の数です
児童養護施設に入りたくて
入っている訳ではありませんよ 子供は
いろんな理由で
親を亡くしてしまったり
また 虐待を受けてしまって
親元を離れなければ
ならなくなってしまった子供たちが
行かなければいけなくなるのが
児童養護施設なんです
じゃあ 皆さん
児童養護施設って
どんな場所か想像できますか？
私がいた施設はこんな場所です
これはイランの児童養護施設です
一見 楽しそうに
確かにケーキを囲んで
みんなで食事をしていますが
食事を見たり 甘いケーキを見たら
みんな自然とハッピーになります
なかなか お菓子なんて
でてこないので
ですけども心の中では
すごく寂しかったです
誰かに抱っこされることもなければ
頭を撫でてもらうこともない
心に受ける闇は
それぞれにありました
今度はこちらをご覧ください
これは日本のとある
児童養護施設の写真です
お部屋にベッドが
ずらっと並んでいますね
このベッドの上が
それぞれに与えられた
スペースなわけです
みんなで生活をしているのが
ここの児童養護施設
でも 子供たちの面倒を
見てくれる人もちゃんといるんです
でも 大人１人に対し
多いときでは
10人の子供の面倒を
見なければなりません
そうすると 子供って
それぞれに個性があったり
考え方もばらばらですよね？
面倒を見る方は
結構大変だったと思います
でも 私としたら本当は
１人１人の子供に
愛情を注いで欲しい
１人１人のちゃんと勉強を
見てあげて欲しいと思うんですけども
それが叶わないのが現状です
でも 子供はね それを理解するまで
時間がかかるので
「なんで ちゃんと
もっと向き合ってくれないんだろう？」
って思ってしまうんですよ
そんな子供が
言っていた言葉があります
「どうせ職員は仕事でしょ」って
「仕事だから僕たちの
相手をしてくれてるだけ
心から愛してくれてる
わけじゃない」
「心から愛してくれてる
これってすごく
私は この言葉を
その子から聞くと心が痛みます
きっと 職員は
そんなつもりはないと思います
一生懸命接してくれてるのが
本当です
だけど 子供が受ける心は
それがリアルなんです
また 施設だけではなくて
学校でも
冷たい言葉を沢山
かけられることがあります
私もありました
先生に「ここ わかりません」って
「教えてください」って言ったら
「あ どうせ 施設の子だろ」
って言われるんですよ
また 他の子たちには
「君たちは僕たちの
税金で生活をしてるんでしょ？」
って言われたり
また 学校に行くと
例えば修学旅行とか遠足
ってありますよね？
そうすると
「あなたは施設から来るんでしょ？
大丈夫なの？ お金あるの？」
って言われるんです
それは ある意味
差別だと私は思います
なんで そんなこと
言われなければいけないんでしょうか？
同じように 私たちも
確かに実の親は
いないかもしれない
また 元々の親のもとを
離れなければいけないけれども
でも 同じ人間なんです
同じように転んで
傷口から出てくる血の色は
みんなと一緒
悔しくて流す涙だって
一緒なんです
なんで そこで境界線を
引かれなければならないんですか？
でも 実際こういう
子供たちというのは
皆さんの国民でもあるんです
だからこそ
見て見ぬ振りをしてはいけない
この現状に気づいていただきたい
と私は思います
続いてこちらをご覧ください
これは2011年度に発表された
養子縁組が成立した
子供の数
430人しかいないんです
全体の１%にも
ほとんど行き届いていないのが
現状なんです
この養子縁組というのは
親戚同士でされる場合も
多いんですけれども
私たち お母さんみたいに
血の繋がりがないもの同士の
養子縁組っていうのは
日本ではほとんど ないんですね
「なぜなんだろう？」と
私は疑問に思いました
血の繋がりって
そんなに関係ありますか？
本当は心と心が繋がれば
本当の親子になれる
と私は思います
母は私を引き取ったときに
実の両親から縁を切られました
今は仲直りしてるんですけども
でも実の両親って
血の繋がりありますよね
縁を切られた
でも血の繋がりのない私のことを
彼女は一度も
「あなたを引き取って損をした」
とは言わなかった
「私はあなたをちゃんと育てることで
社会に見せたい
血の繋がりがなくても
施設の子供であっても
立派な大人になることができる
夢さえ持てれば」
彼女のおかげで
今の私があるんです
彼女に私はこの間
故郷に帰った時に言われました
「自分の国の
いた施設を訪れてみて」と
自分のいた施設
20年ぶりに行ったとき
すごい緊張しました
でも そこに居た人たちが
「ああ ナリゲス あなたなの？
大きくなったね
今 なにしてるの？」って
きいてくれたんですよ
で「私は今 日本で頑張ってるよ」
って言ったら
「すごい 日本にまで行ったの？
他の子供たちの
勇気になるから頑張って」って
言ってくれたんです
でも 施設にいた子供たち
「ねえ どんな夢持ってるの？」
って言ったら
「うーん わかんない
ただお母さんが欲しい」
って言うんです
夢を持ってない子が多いんです
いや 夢が持てないのかもしれない
なぜなら
どうしてったらいいのか
分からないんだと思うんですね
本当だったら親がいて
親に色々 相談をして
背中を支えて[もらって]
１人の人の瞳に自分の姿が
映るということを感じ取るのが
一般的な社会だと思う
でも そこに虐待でしたり
色んな理由で
親元を離れなければ
いけなくなってしまったとき
それを辿れる場所がない
独りぼっちになってしまう
子たちが沢山いるのが
今なんですよね
でも その子たちは
後に施設を出なければならない
社会に ある意味
放り出されてしまったときに
夢が持てないまま—
持てないまま出て行ってしまったら
どうしていいか分からない
でも それを
じゃあ 見て見ぬ振りをしていいか
って言われたらしてはいけない
だって その子たちと
今 皆さんの周りに
もしかしたら
そういう子がいるかもしれない
それに私たち１人１人が気づいて
ちゃんと見てあげることが
必要だという風に思います
私が思うのは
夢
夢ってすごく大切
私は母と出会って
夢を持てたことで
前を見ることができた
ちょっと前の私は
後ろばかり見ていた
いや 立ち止まっていたと思います
でも母と出会って
夢を持ったことで
今の私の夢は
役者をやっているんですけれども
役者として成功して
賞を取って それを
母にプレゼントしたい
彼女と血の繋がりはないけれども
彼女がしてくれたことを
私はお金では返せない
だけで私がこうやって
頑張れたという姿を
夢を持てたということは
彼女に対しての
１つの恩返しだという風に
私は思っています
そして２つ目の私の夢は
「サヘルの家」を作ることです
サヘルの家というのは
児童養護施設のことを
私は表しています
なぜ 家を付けたかと言うと
私は家というものが
必要だと思っているからです
日本に来てすごく感じた
素晴らしい会話を耳にしました
それは カチャン
「ただいま」って言うと
「おかえりなさい」って
言ってくれますよね
「いってきます」って言ったら
「いってらっしゃい」って
言ってくれる
その関係 その会話って
素晴らしいじゃないですか？
でも 今その会話すら
日本の中でも減ってきてると思います
血の繋がりのある親子同士でも
今お互いを傷つけてると思います
それをなくしたいし
今日 ここにいらっしゃる
皆さんにも言いたいのは
第１歩として
１つ目のステップとして
まず これだけの子供たちが今
親の温もりを求めていること
夢が持てない子供たちが
これだけ沢山いるということを
皆さんは今日知れた
この知ったからこそ
次なるステップは
施設に行ってみてください
子供と触れあってみてください
別に子供はお金を求めていません
会って会話をするだけで
１人１人の目を見てあげるだけで
あなたはちゃんとここに
存在してるんですよ と
言ってあげることが
１番のまず第１歩だと思います
是非 生まれてきた子供たちに
生まれてきて良かったな
と感じてもらえる
そんな社会にしていけたら
いいなと思います
１人１人の子供に
夢を そして家庭を
そして皆さん 今日いらっしゃる
皆さんもそうですが
大人になっても
この夢を持ち続けてください
私はこれからも
これを言い続けたいですし
今 日本でも沢山の施設に
足を運んでいます
いつかその施設で今日出会った
皆さんとも出会えたら嬉しいです
そして帰ったら皆さん
大切な人を抱きしめてあげてくださいね
明日があるか
誰にも分かりません
１日１日を大切に生きてください
最後までお話を聴いてくださって
ありがとうございました
(拍手)